[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'ils sont là il ya bien sûr baba la
fouine et baba foba séraphine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais non
alors attention regardez ce voyage est
ce que nos pères faites attention bombe
a sonné chez quelqu'un ali ben je sais
pas je me trompe
oulala plus de volume au niveau des chez
les winners et qui est cette fois ci la
tv en décapotable me suis posé la
question arrivante je suis est ce que
c'est pas trop voulu des chefs de renom
regardez regardez la maison à la même
couleur de jeu et il y en a qui est très
vite en est une qui est très belle salle
chauffée un défi pour toi est ce que tu
es prête à faire le même portée que
notre contemporain avec cyril hanouna
bonne chance le même porte et alors il a
dit cyril hanouna mais j'ai changé
ça va être avec claudie puisqu'il va
absolument danser avec faut hélas la
position du tambour fès a lancé pendant
longtemps on a tous regardé
j'aurais bien voulu
ou des quartiers avait pas d'accord et
en fait il faut pas que tu vois là
justement
bon c'était un rugbyman cote effroi que
tu me charpy suis tu va vouloir
présenter aux plats ou et c'est justice
et tous montés en fait je vais
m'accrocher là avec mes jean louis nadal
a donc mon dos va être plaqué at on vu
ce troquet d'acheter être foster égalité
ah oui ok maintenant je descends week la
claque est maintenant
[Applaudissements]
plus d'un
il travaille pour ça
[Applaudissements]
je sais pas que cette époque comme ça la
danse moi qu'est ce que je pensais que
là dedans c'était un peu avant scène
quand c'est changer la danse maintenant
ça t'apporte partout bah oui on va
démarrer avec la fouine la fouine
l'animal donc que vous allez devoir
intégrer à votre danse la fluide c'est
le kangoo
[Musique]
merci l'affairé woerth j'allais devoir
intégrer dans votre corps et graphie le
holà dans la grotte fois de sexy faut
bannir est toujours sexy pauvre la pluie
c'est à vous allez devoir intégrer à
l'éléphant c'est pas évident sais pas
comment sortez pas votre club
[Musique]
vous allez devoir intégrer le singe pour
me voir à la télé
oui oui
je vais
voilà
[Musique]